our US contractor has been killed in an
attack on an Iraqi military base several
rockets were fired into the base near
Kirkuk that houses both Iraqi and US
troops several service personnel were
also injured Simona Fulton has more from
Baghdad on that attack this attack
occurred last night it was several
rockets that hit inside the k-1 military
base which houses both US forces as well
as iraqi forces in this space is used to
launch important operations against
against isil who have staged an
insurgency in the surrounding mountains
now this is just the latest in a spate
of similar rocket attacks but it's the
first time that we're actually seeing US
casualties there has not been any
responsibility attributed to this but
unofficially one member of the u.s.
coalition told me that it bears similar
hallmarks to previous attacks which were
attributed to the iranian-backed armed
group Khattab Hezbollah now secretary of
state max Pompeo said on december 13th
that any such attacks would be met with
decisive force so it remains to be seen
whether following these u.s. casualties
there will actually be such a response
and of course this raises great concerns
here in Iraq because it's supposed to be
the Iraqi government to actually protect
US forces based here and the government
did promise an investigation but on the
part of US forces they simply feel that
with the increase of such attacks they
may need to protect themselves and of
course there is a real risk that should
the u.s. respond
there could be an escalation here on the
ground between US forces and Iranian
backed armed groups
Roger Shanahan's with us now on skype
from sydney he is a research fellow at
the loi institute an institute for
international policy Roger just to build
on what Simona was saying and without
stating the obvious this does escalate
things isn't it rocket attacks sustained
rocket attacks are one thing but when a
u.s. contractor loses their life it ups
the stakes certainly I think there'll be
a lot riding on the investigation or the
inquiry that US forces will be doing
inside Iraq because that will obviously
determine the next steps that u.s.
authorities are going to have to take
whether they follow up on Secretary of
State on payos threats or whether
they're able to attribute this to
Islamic state or whether it's
indeterminate but the investigation is
really the next step in this matter
regardless of who's behind that is it Oh
are they capitalizing on a moment of
weakness because the protests have
really taken over Iraq for the last few
months the political situations know
better over the country after so many
years of being vulnerable seems even
more vulnerable well again we're gonna
have to determine who who launched this
rocket attack
it's obviously pursuing the interests of
Islamic States also potentially assuring
the interests of iranian-backed militias
forces in Iraq as well so the motives
behind a potential attack are common to
both threat groups for the Americans so
really these it's a large US target to
attack and so we're really gonna have to
wait until we've got a bit more
information from the US authorities
about this one but still just to build
on this point about and I guess this is
more widely talking about Iraq the
weakness in the country at the moment
can you see any obvious way out or
something which will which will
strengthen the government which will
strengthen the people's belief in their
leaders well as you point out you know I
a well-functioning government with full
control over security within the country
would make these kind of attacks if not
impossible them very difficult to
undertake we've seen a ratcheting up in
the number of attacks directed against
us targets in particular from Iranian
back militia groups in Iran until we get
some kind of solution to Iraq's
political problem that is acceptable to
the population in general until we get
a reduction in the degree of corruption
in Iraqi politics until we get some kind
of unity in the country the reality is
that you're going to have to expect more
fracturing around the edges as we've
seen today
Roger Shanahan joining us from Sydney
talking about the latest situation in
Iraq Thank You Roger - appreciate that
my pleasure